boa tarde hoje foi apresentada eu sou
brasileira mas aqui eu sou a argentina
está e eu estou muito feliz com essa
oportunidade e eu vou começar a falar
a offshore é falando uma coisa que para
mim é muito importante e eu vou tentar
vocês entenderem o que eu vou falar
agora com a minha trajetória
então há a forma como a gente enfrenta
as dificuldades em moldar o nosso futuro
e é isso que eu vou tentar mostrar pra
vocês hoje eu quero que vocês olharem
para essa imagem e por um segundo pensar
se o que vocês sentem ao ver essa imagem
se sentir felizes ficam alegres cento e
tristes
o que você sente ao ver sua imagem essa
imagem porque não a fotografia e fahel
não é uma imagem ilustrativa de onde
vive boa parte de minha infância mais ou
menos até os 12 anos
eu vivia numa casa muito similar a essa
e como você pode ver não tinha
saneamento saneamento básico
hoje eu sei que o saneamento básico é um
direito básico e por muito tempo eu não
tive o básico mas a vida foi mostrando
que é preciso a gente ter determinação
para encarar as dificuldades porque
dificuldade todo mundo tem incrivelmente
todo mundo tem até a pessoa que você
acha que tem muito grande monta todo não
tem dificuldades mas a forma como a
gente encara como a gente vê moldou
nosso futuro e hoje estou aqui tá aqui
uma foto edson sem três irmãs
eu sou a rua geni a mais velha
criativamente a do meia roger eni ea
mais nova rosangela e essa foto é muito
representativa pra mim porque mesmo em
meio a tanta escassez
há tanta falta de tantas coisas
a minha mãe ensinava que era preciso ser
feliz mesmo na escassez
então por mais que você veja a foto de
crianças pobres você vê cores você vê
crianças que não estão abatidas
diante das dificuldades e aqui é eu nem
a melhor amiga que foi muito tempo a
gente estudou juntos juntas
minha irmã joelho eu sou mais velha do
que ela três anos e durante a infância
gente incrivelmente eu era uma criança
muito tímida muito calada
olha como a vida na música é isso aí ea
gente que sempre viveu muito junta há
muito tempo depois de cinco anos que viu
a mais nova então sempre éramos nós dois
e sempre estamos na mesma escola e
diversas vezes
inúmeras vezes não conseguiria elenca a
quantidade de vezes a gente ia para a
escola tem o direito de ter lanche e as
criancinhas todas a maioria tinha lanche
e um belo dia a gente estava com fome e
agora sim muito passivo assim a nano eu
não gostava de ser um peso
aí eu pensei vou beber água daqui a
pouco a fome passa e fica na minha
espera no recreio acabar daqui a pouco
em meio à rosilene ela é mais enérgica
significar mais enérgica que eu hoje em
o gênio que foi menina ela olha que o
nosso lanche
eu a pensar roubo e roubo vai apanhar
uma menina quente ou lanche a mãozinha
dela cheia de biscoitos ayew ela não
intimidou não eu peguei no chão
aí pra que time aquilo ali foi algo
cortante pra mim porque como na minha
cabeça sim se você comia lixo que coisa
deixar lixo
você também é lixo e eu pensei não possa
ser isso aí eu peguei cathels biscoito
na mão dela e joguei no lixo e ali eu
teve um momento muito marcante na minha
vida porque eu sou muito apegada à minha
família à minha mãe minhas irmãs ktm ela
fomos um banheiro e com lágrimas nos
olhos eu jurei a pela minha vida que a
gente sairia da
pela história eu criança eu não entendia
mas eu sabia que aquele presente não era
pra mim tinha algo muito mais reservado
para nós e eu tinha vários futebolistas
e sim muito muito muito grande de sonhos
inclusive gravar o ted era um deles
bravo mas só que eu gostaria que você
tentasse adivinhar qual foi meu primeiro
sonho qual fosse um sonho que eu
persegui anos para conquistar quem só
usa se você acertou
era isso comer um biscoito de morango
pra mim o ifr lá a gente chama de iof eu
não sei aqui na argentina era a coisa
mais gostosa do mundo
eu via passava na prateleira conseguia
sentir o gosto e eu fui casa e minha mãe
já educou de tal forma assim nunca peça
nunca seja peso não sabe então eu não
pedia talvez eu pedisse ele teria
realizado muito cedo e sonho e eu fui
realizar esse sonho somente aos 15 anos
esperar um pouco de tempo mas eu
realizei e no dia que eu realizei esse
sonho eu lembro como hoje eu estava na
praça sentada e eu tinha comprado dois
biscoitos que é uma pessoa tinha me dado
uma gorjeta como se fosse 5 reais eu não
sei como seria aclamado de vocês mas
seria r$5 não é um dinheiro e eu pensei
assim o que eu ia fazer com cinco reais
aí eu pensei eu voltar pra minha mãe pra
ajudar na casa
tá na hora de realizar meu sonho nessa
hora que você tem é bom isso comprar a
eu comprei dois pacotes com explosivos
gente por favor desculpa e outro eu
levei para casa e naquele momento aliás
15 anos eu entendi que nada pra mim era
mais impossível
tudo era possível e então esse aí foi o
meu primeiro e maior sonho
nada me tocou tanto como aquele biscoito
de morango
do outro lado
eu tive um maior desafio na minha vida e
eu pergunto a vocês o que uma criança de
7 anos pequenininha se preocupa
quais são as preocupações de uma criança
de sete anos a meus sete anos eu já
trabalhava eu já trabalhava com os pais
na feira e era parte do meu dia a dia e
para feira trabalhar para ajudar no
sustento da casa
até aí tudo bem quanto as crianças no
trabalho mas viu outro agravante
meu pai tinha sérios problemas não só
com álcool mas com outros tipos de
drogas
isso tudo afetava a nossa relação
familiar
até aí tudo bem quantas pessoas não
passam por isso
por fim um outro agravante o que
acontecia durante os meus primeiros sete
anos eu penso quem pra quem tem pacu
quem é pai maior mensagem pra você você
quer ver seu filho feliz
ame sua esposa nada faz mais feliz uma
criança do que o pai
amando e respeitando a sua mãe isso toca
ela de uma forma extremamente assim não
tem como explicar
às vezes a dona helen sua mas se você vê
a sua mãe sofrem no você vai sentir no
lugar dela e quando falo que minha mãe
sofreu violência doméstica porque assim
ele batia na gente ele espancava a gente
mas de alguma forma entendia ele é pai
ele pode mas quando vi ele fazendo isso
com a minha mãe eu achava que isso era
demais pra mim e quando falo que ele
batia na minha mãe não tô falando de
tapas
uma das vezes que mais marcou a minha
vida foi ver o meu pai é aquele que me
gerou junto com minha mãe dando tanto no
rosto dela que quebrou o nariz léo
áquilla ele foi demais pra mim é
possível na possível então vem o maior
desafio eu há sete anos eu não sabia ler
meus colegas todos sabiam ler e eu não
sabia ler e aí
a professora chamou a minha mãe e fala
assim nossa hoje nesse lente roger no
conversa
roger não falta roger não se atrasa mas
ela não aprende a lei
eu não sei mais o que fazer com o gene e
aí minha mãe fala assim com ela
professora muito obrigada pelos seis
fosse eu queria pedir uma chance
me dá um mês foi trabalhar com o gene e
ela faz a prova
se ela não conseguir nós aceitaremos que
realmente ela não vai poder progredir
com a turnê e eu tipo assim eu era
criança mas entendia que alguma coisa
estava dando muito linda cheia de roupa
alguma coisa não tá certo ali e aí fomos
para casa eu estava de lado minha irmã
rosa além do outro e foi um seguindo
durante o meu todo a minha mãe ficou em
silêncio e eu pensei vou tomar um couro
bem d'água e eu quando chegou lá em casa
eu pensei que ia tomar a sua mas
surpreendentemente a minha mãe falou uma
palavra motivacional que mudou toda a
minha história até então o meu futuro
era a próxima refeição
a partir deste momento pra frente mudou
alguma coisa no meu cérebro mudou eu
gostaria de destacar que a poder na
palavra tanto para você construir quanto
você destruir e quando minha mãe dela
olha o cinto ali olhando nos olhos e
fala se filha que nasceu para brilhar
o seu futuro será extraordinário e
aquela aquelas palavras entraram assim
dentro de mim eu não sabia o que estava
acontecendo eu queria ser extraordinário
eu não sabia mais o que era e eu prometi
pra mim mesma que independente do que
acontecesse ao meu redor
eu iria estudar e ser boa aluna durante
um mês eu pedi tanto a deus me ajude
deus me ajude por favor aprender a ler
eu preciso aprender ali e deus me
abençoou e nunca reprovei de ana vem
eu sou muito feliz e durante a i don't
pergunta e só para o que aconteceu né a
gente ficou com ele em casa até os 15
anos ou mais os meus 15 anos ea gente
começou a mudar
as estratégias quando a gente sai de
casa e aqui aquelas meninas lá de trás
lembra caminha que somos nós
eu pensei a gente vai vencer pelos
estudos
e aí comecei a pensar vamos estudar o
custo da bolsa brasileira para a
biblioteca estudo estudo estudo e eu em
2015 cinco conseguir bolsa de estudos
para fazer administração de empresas
trabalhei em boas empresas e em 2014 eu
fui admitida na melhor universidade do
brasil pra fazer mestrado em
contabilidade na usp
e aí eu fui cabeça eu não quero que eu
seja a filha rica da família né eu quero
que todo mundo avance e aqui tá rosilene
e embaixo da foto dela na primeira
formatura dela ela entrou na
universidade federal da bahia fez a
primeira graduação e na na mesma noite
da formatura ela recebeu a notícia que
ela foi aceita no curso de direito
também na universidade federal da bahia
fez não entendam o que é mas é uma
universidade muito difícil entrar e ela
entrou ea angela ela diga que a vida foi
mais confortável rafael navarro também
bastante
ela fez todo o ensino médio uma baita
escola federal e ela não nunca precisou
fazer cursinho e hoje ela faz ué cursa
engenharia ambiental também na
universidade federal da bahia e minha
mãe depois de 50 anos formou-se em
técnica de enfermagem
eu brinco se a gente termina aqui a
nossa minha história
jamais uma baita história né mas deus
está reservando algo muito maior para a
gente aqui é a mesma hoje lenny em 2017
ela foi aceita para fazer intercâmbio
cultural na universidade de coimbra que
é o berço do direito e lá ela passou
dois anos e voltou no brasil este ano
eu tinha um desejo muito grande quando
fui para são paulo é ribeirão preto pra
fazer mestrado eu tinha vontade de ter
uma experiência no limite
quem conheceu martin que já fala de
marketing é uma boa escola lá vai eu era
aquela menina lembra assim querendo
emblemático e eu queria
queria queria queria queria dizer fala
assim deus minha mostra um caminho
incrivelmente no meu primeiro dia de
aula no mestrado na usp
eu conheci um professor do emitir que
mudaria toda a minha trajetória
naquele dia quando eu vi ele falando na
usp
eu falei assim meu deus que o homem de
deus que palavras com que ele fala essas
coisas e ali eu tinha certeza que iria
promete e eu passei anos sonhando de
2014 até 2018 ano passado e eu sempre um
jaleco do emitir pra quê pra mim era
certo pra mim era certeza eu vou
então assim eu já uso porque eu já serei
estarem lá então é certeza que irei e
deixou muito bom com a gente
e aqui é a minha primeira foto don
emmert ano passado em outubro eu passei
sete meses lá aprendendo várias coisas e
eu fiquei muito feliz porque o meu
destino e teoricamente estava traçado
todo mundo poderia olhar cinco crianças
daquela qual o futuro caminha juntei e
as pessoas às vezes a outra falava ó não
que futuro pai todo problemático a mãe
sem estudos com o qual o futuro dessas
meninas mas a minha mãe foi uma pessoa
muito sábio e ela conseguiu colocar as
três ilhas nas melhores universidades
talvez ninguém nunca disse isso pra você
mas pode ter certeza você nasceu para
brilhar e seu futuro será extraordinário
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]